what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
delving deep into the concept of curses
and forbidden magic which are notions
that have been present in black clovers
since the very beginning but they have
been touched on only briefly and as of
right now they still remain a big
mystery
however in the most recent arcs of the
black clover story forbidden magic has
taken center stage and we recently
learned something shocking about
Noelle's mother and the Silva family
that is sure to be extremely important
in the future what's more we also
learned the identity of a brand-new
demon a demon who could end up being the
next major villain of the series so we
are now at the point where curses and
forbidden magic have to be addressed and
explained and that is exactly what I
will be doing right here in this video
if you enjoy the black clover content on
this channel and you want to see more
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
please don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification valve to turn on all
notifications now you might have noticed
that some of our older black clover
videos are no longer available here on
the channel for the time being because
we are currently dealing with some false
copyright strikes if you'd like to stay
up to date on stuff like this including
when our videos are gonna be back online
please follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar we use twitter
and instagram every single day to keep
you guys posted about the latest updates
for black clover other anime and about
the channel as well and finally this
video will contain manga spoilers we are
dealing with all the latest information
that we have about the new demon about
curses and about forbidden magic so if
you're not caught up to the manga please
proceed with caution you have been
warned throughout the black clovers
story there have been multiple instances
of forbidden magic being used licked
used forbidden magic to turn himself
into the giant demon which he did in
order to prevent the devil from
possessing his body
sacré used forbidden magic in order to
temporarily seal away that same devil
and the devil himself used forbidden
magic in order to activate the
reincarnation magic on the elves we know
that
the world of black clover regular curse
magic exists and we've seen multiple
people use curse based magic spells
including Katherine and I believe that
Gordon and second also have curse based
spells in their magic arsenal but there
is also curse magic that is different
because it is connected to forbidden
magic in Chapter two two one
Charlotte tells Yami that forbidden
magic gets its power from the next world
which is presumably the alternate
dimension where the demons reside
forbidden magic interferes with the
nature of this world with the nature of
life the curse that was supposed to
activate when Charlotte turned eighteen
was going to forcibly change the form of
her soul and the nature of her magic and
there was no one in the kingdom who knew
how to break the curse but Yami
eventually managed to do it by stealing
Charlotte's heart although the fact that
Yami was able to break the curse may
also have something to do with the
unique nature of Yami's dark magic which
as we learned is one of the very few
types of magic that has an effect on the
kotodama devil so that's something to
think about by the way in case you
haven't noticed by now Charlotte's story
is basically the story of Sleeping
Beauty except both the beauty and the
prince charming who breaks the curse are
badass magic knight captains Charlotte
then says that in terms of forbidden
magic curses she knows of one that is
far stronger than the curse that had
affected her and that stronger curse
affected one of the members of the black
bulls and on the very next page we see
Noelle approaching Dorothy Unsworth and
asking her how her mother ah ca Silva
and the demon are related as Noelle
approaches Dorothy Dorothy is in the
process of clearing out the rubble
caused by the elf conflict by
teleporting it into her magical dream
dimension known as glamour world I have
to say that this is a really cool and
useful ability and I am glad that we are
learning more about Dorothy because her
magic is just so awesome and we've seen
so little of her as a character Dorothy
reveals that because she is all of
glamour world under her complete control
she also uses it to keep naughty people
inside as prisoners
or to transport people and things
through it it is definitely a bad idea
to mess with Dorothy if you get on her
bad side she could trap you inside a
dream world that she controls completely
and turn your every nightmare into a
reality scary stuff man
scary stuff Noel is shocked that Dorothy
is able to use magic on such a large
scale especially if she has this entire
dream world under her complete control
this scene from chapter 2 - - definitely
reminds us that Dorothy is easily one of
the most Opie characters in the entire
series if the elf would possess her body
had more experience with Dorothy's dream
magic I don't think she would have been
defeated this magic is just so ope when
used the right way so as I said in
Chapter two to one we learned that
Noelle's mother ah ca Silva is somehow
related to a demon and two forbidden
magic and in Chapter two two two
Dorothy reveals that Noelle's mother
died of a curse that was set upon her by
a demon in fact this curse is so
powerful than anyone who talks about it
will themselves be cursed and this is
why Noelle's brother knows L never told
anyone about what really happened
but since Dorothy is able to take Noel
inside her glamour world they are free
to safely discuss the curse because
glamour world is separated from the
outside world at this point
Dorothy explains that under normal
circumstances demons cannot manifest in
this world they are from another
dimension and they should not be
appearing in this world unless something
is seriously wrong the only way for
demons to enter this world is if
something out of the ordinary happens
and in fact in the past certain mages
were able to use forbidden magic to make
a deal with the devil in order to get
more power if a mage is willing to
sacrifice something and make a contract
in order to get the power of the demons
they are able to break the barrier that
separates this world from the world of
the demons Dorothy says that something
must have gone wrong either during one
of these ceremonies or in some other way
because the shadow of the demons is now
wriggling around in this world it seems
that the barrier between the demon world
and the normal world is not as strong as
it once was and more demonic power has
been infiltrating the non demon
world Dorothee reveals that a demon
exists by the name of Maggie Kula or
magic Kula I'm just gonna say Maggie
Cola anyway
this demon is responsible for the death
of Noelle's mother what's more this
mysterious demon could also be the key
to saving Austin but who is Maggie Kula
and where is this demon now more
importantly what is this new demon
planning and how are the demons plans
going to affect the wider black clover
story we only see a single extremely
dark depiction of this demon on the very
last page of chapter 2 - - so there
isn't too much that we can extrapolate
from that but if this depiction of
Maggie Kula is accurate it suggests that
Maggie Cola is a completely new and as
of right now unknown demon if we look at
this demons twisted horns they look like
the horns of a ram and they are not like
the horns of any of the other demons
that we have seen so far and this
includes the giant demon that left
transformed into the kotodama devil and
the demon inside of Asta's grimoire none
of these other demons appear to have the
same downward twisting horns as Maggie
Kula appears to have and so if this is
indeed an accurate depiction and Maggie
kala is a completely new and unique
demon and not say Asta's demons true
name or something along those lines then
it is safe to assume that this Maggie
Kula will be the next major villain of
the series don't forget that we recently
learned that one of the three kingdoms
which border the clover kingdom and more
specifically the Spade Kingdom is known
as the demon kingdom of spade it is
believed that something evil and demonic
resides within the Spade Kingdom and
that the recent military expansion of
the Spade Kingdom could be the result of
its citizens using forbidden magic and
demonic power to advance their goals and
of course we recently learned that the
black balls will be leaving the clover
kingdom and going somewhere else in the
next arc so that is the perfect setup
for Austin the black balls to come
face-to-face with the demon king no
Spade and a demon Maggie Kula but I'm
about to say something that might sound
a bit crazy don't be surprised if it
turns out that Noelle's mother ah CA
Silva is not really dead
at this point we all believe that she
died as a result of a curse placed on
her by the demon McGee Kula but that
description of her death sounds too
vague for my tastes
don't forget what demons from the
Otherworld do they possess the bodies of
others so that they can be manifested
into this world I wouldn't be surprised
if McGee Kula didn't kill OCA Silva
but rather possessed her body the curse
that was placed on rc8 didn't kill her
but rather put her under the control of
the demon McGee Kula this might seem odd
to believe since we've been told that
hacia is dead and her children believe
that she is dead but if vasya's body has
been taken over by a demon it would be
easier and more merciful to tell her
children that she died rather than to
tell them the truth
that their mother is alive but that she
is also an evil demon who is doing all
sorts of terrible things over in the
Spade Kingdom don't forget the classic
Star Wars twist obi-wan tells Luke that
his father is dead and that he was
killed by Darth Vader but it turns out
that Luke's father is not dead because
Luke's father is none other than Darth
Vader himself sorry for the
forty-year-old spoiler by the way it was
easier for obi-wan to tell Luke that his
father died a hero than to tell him that
his father actually became a ruthless
villain I think something similar could
be happening with OCA Silva and the
demon McGee Kula I could be totally
wrong and if I am I accept all the
well-deserved criticism but I just get
the feeling that something is off with
this whole assi a Silva story I mean
think about it we've all been wondering
what new villain could possibly match
the power of the kotodama devil who was
incredibly Opie and who was only
defeated as a direct result of the joint
efforts of all the most powerful
fighters in the clover Kingdom except
for Julius who was kind of dead at the
time but psych not really so who could
possibly live up to the hype of the
kotodama devil as the next big villain
well how about the woman who was so
strong that she trained mera Luna but
even mera Luna with all her power never
once succeeded in defeating her now
imagine this same woman's powers being
combined with the powers of a demon and
not only will this new
willenby incredibly powerful the twist
and the family connection to Noel would
add another dimension of interest and
hype to the story get it another
dimension anyway I don't know why I'm
here going on record with such a crazy
theory and making sure that everyone can
come back to this video and mock me if
it doesn't turn out to be true
but I just have a feeling that the story
of hacia Silva is not over yet I also
found it very interesting to learn that
in order for a demon to be able to
manifest in this world in the first
place a mage has to willingly engage in
forbidden magic and sacrifice something
important does this mean that someone
willingly summoned the kotodama devil
500 years ago and sacrificed something
important to make it happen also was
Austin's demon summoned by someone in
particular for some particular reason or
was his appearance just a side effect of
the fact that the kotodama devil created
the 5-leaf grimoire there is just so
much that we still don't know about the
demons and I am very excited about the
fact that this new arc is shaping up to
be one that is focused on a new demon by
the name of Meggie Kula although the
word saga might be more accurate than
the word arc because we might have
multiple separate but related arcs
taking place before we actually get to
the new big boss Meggie Kula let me know
what you guys think
are you excited but the reveal of Meggie
Kula the new demon and do you agree with
me that something isn't quite right
about the death of hacia Silva let me
know down in the comments if you enjoyed
the black clover content on this channel
you want to see more please leave a like
to let me know and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications follow us
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest black clover news and
updates I want to give a big thank you
to all of our anime outpour patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thanks to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings eldress on hell
cruise stealers poet Pablo atropos
Wraith and fitty dalla beat and also an
epic thank you to all of ours the one
tier patrons the ones who stand up up
all other clans including Ingrid ah a
Lola madam madam AK and makoto-kun if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron only discord and to
show our gratitude your name will appear
in our videos along with these amazing
people as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see us
bass Cowboys
[Music]